En 2014 la chanteuse
Beyoncé se lancait dans une tournée
mondiale intitulée
"Mrs Carter Show"
sur
l'écran géant derrière la scène on
pouvait lire en lettres capitales le mot
féministe suivi d'une définition
la chanteuse s'autoproclamait porte parole
de la cause
et le fait est que cela a marché
beaucoup de personnes et surtout des
femmes ont vu dans ses textes, ses
performances live, et ses clips une forme
de célébration de la femme, de son
corps, de son pouvoir.
Personnellement ça m'a toujours frappée
qu'il puisse être considérée comme une
icône féministe.
Toutes les féministes
ne seront pas d'accord avec le discours
de la star mais il faut bien avouer que
Beyoncé a réussi à incarner pour le
grand public une forme de lutte féministe.
Pourtant dans "Who run the world ? Girls"
clip qui compte presque 400 millions
de vues sur Youtube
si on oublie le texte un instant qui
nous dit donc que les femmes
dirigent le monde on voit exactement le
contraire :
un groupe de femmes, parfois à terre,
jambes levées, en porte-jarretelles
faisant ça c'est un groupe d'hommes.
Des hommes bien mieux préparés qu'elles
pour diriger le monde
ils sont armés protégés de casques et
de boucliers avec de bonnes chaussures.
Après un flot d'images subliminales
où la femme est exposée, aspergée,
encerclée
le clip se termine par ce plan
où les femmes font le salut militaire
qui n'est même pas rendu par les
hommes.
Conclusion, les femmes ne dirigent
pas le monde
elles subissent tous les ressorts visuels
de la domination masculine.
Bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour un
nouvel épisode de "La Modernité" un
épisode vous allez le voir qui colle
particulièrement à l'actualité
puisque on va parler de la femme et de
l'image de la femme
Pour ce qui est des images cette domination se
manifeste de nos jours avant tout dans
la publicité.
les myriades de photos de
femmes sont destinées à faire consommer
on parle bien de "femme objet".
Les femmes
sont la plupart du temps photographiées
et habillées par des hommes
Elles sont tour à tour égéries de produits de
luxe, muses d'artiste.
Mais est ce là véritablement une place
de marque ?
Une forme d'émancipation pour
les femmes ?
Non, certainement pas, bien
au contraire même et sans entrer dans
une analyse poussée des publicités
actuelles on va pointer quelques uns des
aspects les plus récurrents de notre
manière de montrer les femmes.
Que ce soit à la télé ou dans les magazines
papiers
la femme est le plus souvent
représentée seul et sans décor
ça
veut dire qu'on ne peut pas la
représenter dans l'espace et dans le
temps
il n'y a qu'à regarder la différence
de traitement hommes femmes pour la
vente d'un même produit pour s'en
rendre compte
la femme est souvent représentée dans
un canapé ou en position basse au
niveau des animaux de la saleté
Couchée, elle peu moins se défendre
Etendue sur un lit en pleine journée ce n'est pas pour se reposer
c'est pour exprimer
une disponibilité sexuelle.
au contraire
un homme est toujours situé dans un
décor précis qui suggère une
activité professionnelle ou de détente
si la femme est dans une pièce type
salon ou cuisine
cette pièce sera vide ou quasiment
vides, vous trouverez un accessoire au
maximum un frigo un aspirateur.
Le but étant de supprimer toute
référence au travail et à l'effort.
On ne représente jamais la femme en
train d'en baver, de suer, de froncer
les sourcils et ça depuis au-moins
l'Antiquité.
Les éléments décoratifs
des bâtiments en témoignent les
cariatides, femmes, et les atlantes, hommes,
traduisent ses codes
les atlantes sont toujours en train de
forcer. Leurs muscles sont contractés, ils
font la gueule
normal c'est lourd !
les cariatides, elle,s ont beau avoir le
toit du Louvre sur la tête, elles ne
montrent aucun signe de fatigue
elles sont détendues et toujours bien
coiffées.
L'homme est un héros il plie
sous l'effort la femme est un ornement
sois belle et tais toi en somme.
Donc qu'on récapitule un peu notre bonne femme là
est un corps sans muscle, offert
d'une tranquilité sans borne
bien au chaud dans sa maison.
Et si par un heureux hasard elle vient à sortir de
chez elle pour travailler elle est
encadrée non pas par un mais par
plusieurs hommes.
Et ça n'est pas propre
à notre société contemporaine
les images de femmes sont partout tout
le temps
manipulées par les hommes pour les
hommes.
Prenons un exemple emblématique d'une toute autre époque :
les statuettes préhistoriques.
La Préhistoire nous a livré une quantité
importante d'objets représentant des
femmes ou le sexe féminin en
particulier ce qu'on appelle les
vénus ces petites statuettes en bois ou
en argile très connues pour leurs
formes imposantes,
marquées au niveau des
seins,
des fesses et du bas ventre.
un peu comme Beyoncé !
Beaucoup d'archéologues
y ont vu le symbole de la fertilité, de
la maternité de l'existence d'une
déesse mère et même d'un matriarcat
originel c'est à dire un pouvoir
détenu par les femmes.
Dans leur esprit
être représenté est une marque
d'importance. Si les femmes étaient
sculptées en milliers d'exemplaires
c'était donc qu'elles devaient être
les patronnes, les taulières du bled !
(c'est notre rais à nous)
Un archéologue du futur qui étudierait
notre époque pourrait d'ailleurs
conclure à partir des tonnes de
vestiges de panneaux publicitaires de
magazines et de comptes Instagram que les
femmes du 21e siècle
régissent le monde
Mais bon après tout pourquoi pas, hein ?
Pourquoi les femmes de la préhistoire
n'auraient-elles pas été mieux loties ?
Pourquoi ne serait-ce pas l'indice d'un
matriarcat primitif ?
La réponse est
simple parce que le matriarcat ça n'existe pas
n'en déplaise aux férus
du girl power primitif comme
Marija GImbutas
qui voit en ces statuettes
la force créatrice de la femme mais de
toutes les sociétés humaines connues
aucune n'est dirigée par des femmes à
chaque fois le pouvoir public appartient
aux hommes.
Il y a des sociétés qu'on
dit matrilinéaires où le lignage et les
biens sont transmis par la mère mais
c'est tout !
Le matriarcat ça n'existe
pas à part dans certains mythes chez
les grecs ce sont les Amazones ou encore
chez les Iroquois.
Toutes les décisions
importantes dans les sociétés sont
prises par des hommes pour des hommes et
l'image n'y échappe pas.
Après avoir critiqué l'idée du
matriarcat, que penser d'un culte
ancestral à une déesse mère ?
Dans "déesse-mère", il y a deux termes
déesse, une
divinité dont qui veille sur nous et
à qui on doit rendre culte
et puis l'autre terme "mère" qui renvoie
à la possibilité de donner la vie ou
non.
Lorsqu'on découvre ces statuettes
pour la première fois au Proche et
Moyen-orient, lors de fouilles
archéologiques,
on pense tout de suite qu'il s'agit
d'objets de culte à une déesse.
Une déesse qu'on aime associer aux récoltes
et de manière générale à l'agriculture
en  oubliant au passage que ce type de
représentations existe depuis le
paléolithique période comme vous le
savez où l'agriculture n'existe pas.
Or, lorsqu'on regarde de plus près le
contexte de découverte de ces
statuettes
rien ne permet de prouver qu'elles sont
liées à une quelconque religion.
Elles sont la plupart du temps trouver
en mauvais état, en périphérie de
l'habitat et pas dans des temples.
Pour en finir avec nos Venus que nous
dit l'anthropologie sur leur rôle ?
Pourquoi les hommes sculptent des femmes bien en chair
si ce ne sont ni des cheffes
ni des déesses ?
Pour l'anthropologue Alain Testart
oui je sais encore lui mais que
voulez vous son travail est génial mais
malheureusement peu vulgarisé.
Les femmes sont bonnes à penser
les regarder procure un plaisir
leurs seins,  leurs hanches, leurs fesses stimulent l'imagination.
Regardons les attentivement on voit que
la plupart du temps la vulve est marquée
d'un trait incisé
mais ce qui se démarque le plus de ces pièces
ce sont les seins et surtout les fesses !
Or, les fesses n'ont rien à voir de la
fertilité
c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait les
bébés.
Drôle l'image que celle de la femme
à la fois dépendante des hommes
et maîtresse de maison
j'aurais pu parler des thèses de Pierre
Bourdieu développées dans le livre
"La domination masculine"
mais quitte à parler des femmes autant vous
présenter un travail tout aussi
intéressant sur la question est fait
par une femme
celui de l'historienne Michelle Perrot.
elle explique que la société organise
la différence des sexes
la femme est vue comme un manque déjà
chez les philosophes grecs :
"un réceptacle",  "une statuette mal cuite"
pour Aristote.
La femme est inférieure
par sa génitalité
inférieure et
angoissante son sexe fait peur
le sang
des règles nourri de nombreuses
superstitions
On en avait déjà rapidement
parlé au sujet des Baruya dans une
précédente vidéo
Enfin, le pouvoir qu'ont les femmes de
donner la vie ou non renforce les
craintes à leur égard.
Si un mot
pouvait résumer l'image de la femme ce
serait ambiguïté
dans le traitement
des images la femme est avide ou frigide,
bénéfique ou maléfique
Dans la religion on retrouve aussi tout un panel
de symboles qui renvoie cette
ambivalence.
la périodicité, le temps cyclique qui sont liés à la
maternité
et puis le secret et le mystère autour
de leur sexualité
une sexualité inconnue et méconnue
avec
la crainte de ne pas satisfaire sa
partenaire.
La domination masculine on va le
rappeler ici est une construction
sociale historique mais qui a des
répercussions très concrètes sur nos
vies tant sur celle des femmes que celle
des hommes d'ailleurs.
Cependant croire
qu'on est parti d'une période dirigée
par des femmes
puis que, petit à petit, le pouvoir a
été transmis aux hommes est un schéma
qui ne tient pas.
Croire au matriarcat
c'est accepter l'idéologie de la
domination masculine.
Après avoir dit
tout ça, qu'est ce qu'on peut faire ?
les femmes sont plus nombreuses sur Terre
vivent plus longtemps et sont très
actives dans des tas de domaines
elles sont à la fois sur-représentées
dans le monde publicitaire et, à l'inverse,
manquent cruellement de visibilité
dans les domaines scientifiques
l'histoire par exemple reste écrite le
plus souvent par des hommes et
l'histoire est un récit sans fin, il
faut donc en continuer l'écriture.
Si nous les femmes
manquons de visibilité
nous disposons à présent et à la
différence des époques antérieures
des mêmes outils que les hommes un
clavier pour écrire une connexion
internet pour s'informer
il faut que les femmes écrivent,
laissent une trace et se bougent les
fesses pour ne pas tomber dans l'oubli
en collant une image imposée par une
société patriarcale
et se figer du
même coup
dans un éternel mythe
cet épisode est terminé merci à tous
de l'avoir regardé
n'hésitez pas à le partager c'est une
très bonne manière de soutienir la
chaîne et puis si vous voulez vous
pouvez aussi soutenir financièrement
sur la plateforme Tipeee.
Vous trouverez le
lien en barre d'infos et sur la page
d'accueil de ma chaîne.
Je vous remercie
une dernière fois et je vous dis à la prochaine
Salut !
I like big butts and I can not lie
You other brothers can't deny
That when a girl walks in with an itty bitty waist
And a round thing in your face
You get sprung, wanna pull up tough
'Cause you notice that butt was stuffed
Deep in the jeans she's wearing
I'm hooked and I can't stop staring
Oh baby...